okay in the knife hey now welcome
everyone this is a Android development
office hours live from Devil's Pier in
Antwerp in Antwerp yes I hope you can
hear it in a new easy conference we've
managed to find a little place with some
white lines yeah just a few hours after
the recent Android launches this nexus
10 at Nexus 4 have started shipping and
we've got the new SDK out so we'll be
talking about some of the api's and that
and the new Android developer tools as
well we've got a whole bunch of material
to get through it yeah
as always we'll be taking material from
the moderator which will be able to find
it developers.google.com slash live and
if you comment on the hangout thread as
well on the Google+ plus Android
developers page we'll be able to see
your comments on there and we can invite
you into the Hangout and you can come
along and ask us some questions live at
devoxx before if you're at da but then
come on so many ways to get in touch and
thank you very much Chris again for
joining us in the office hours we make
up for some of our deficiencies in our
limited set up here today because we
can't actually reach the keyboard it's
over there somewhere
no worries we'll be able to see some of
the check questions and hopefully get
back to your questions we weren't trying
to load the moderator on roaming data
excellent so the first technical hitch
pin you can't see the moderator but we
promise to answer your questions on it
oh there's stuff in full point TFS so I
think very exciting 4.2 tonight Amelia
interesting API switch all new
developers in here means they came SDK
manager and downloading the latest and
greatest and going over the API death
seeing what's new and important hmm
so I think the me I think one of the
main things I want to make sure people
are aware about it the changes to
providers so now by default if you're
kind of testing upon them SDK 17 and you
change your target II game that's got an
implementation for the default value for
content providers and exported setting
which means like whether or not you're
exposing your content provider to other
applications
it used to be default to public is now
changed if you came to target Seagate to
default and
not to public so you might if you were
relying on that default value somehow
and not setting it explicitly then you
might have changed behavior so just be
really aware of what that means yeah as
soon as you start talking to get out of
the 17 of you for me it's the new API is
for dreams daydreams and lock screen
widgets I'm most excited about you'll be
giving away some swag here to any
developers at devoxx that come to our
stand with a brand new lock screen
widget or they dream to the daydreams as
you may already know it's like a screen
saver API very similar to like
wallpapers you implement them yourself
you can expose in an interactive manner
your content onto the display of the
device as it goes to sleep or what it's
charging on Tommy
and for me it's the presentation API I
think it's one of the most exciting
advice so lets you create different
content for different screens so it's
been a lot of fuss about the mirror pass
which is coming in the next Explorer
this device did allow wireless sharing
to this place but the same API works
over HDMI as well so you can start
writing applications right now they use
the presentation API and any football to
device to be able to use the Ovation
might as well I think it's a really nice
day for town API and so you get a
different context which you know you
know different assets depending on the
resolution and intensity of the target
display which you're sending into which
is really nice there's a really nice
changes with the media Rueter class so
the media router will allow you to send
content to the best screen available
essentially and also the
mediarouteprovider which will allow you
to route video and audio to the best
kind of like Singapore so some standard
standard components you can put into
your app now to take advantage of these
things so really exciting stuff I can't
wait to see what people build absolutely
from the Stone here at devoxx we're
demoing the Nexus 10 on our 50-inch
plasma screen of course the Nexus 10
with its 2500 by 1600 pixel display it's
to downscale for our 50 inch full HD
plasma like bit on the 58 y'all like it
better on there take every time I say
2500 Ramon tells me offices 2560 and
those extra 60 pixels along with the
extra 48 pixels on the Nexus
we're 7:27 your your you eyes of course
will seems to scale the display
resolution on the nexus 10 as Nick will
demonstrate Flores is still a 10 inch
tablet yeah and this is the first xhdpi
10 inch tablet the previous pretty much
every single previous Android 10 inch
tablet has been MVP I so a resolution
density of one because this is xhdpi
it's got a density of two so all your
layouts that we've done in depth I'm
just going to scale perfectly is what is
1280 by 800 dips the same as the
previous 10 inch tablet yeah one thing
to watch out for is well we've been
testing a bunch of apps on this device
before and orange and pretty much
everything scale beautifully why not
might have used pixel sizing ronin tip
sizing and they find you know most your
content flows nicely and then one
element was too short
it wasn't going well yes a layout that
you saw probably getting the etc yet to
http I folder from your phone's if you
had fun way out some say the they Galaxy
Nexus so I'm hopefully everything will
look perfect you wants just join us down
that just dancing in the hangouts
questions they're gonna have to wave a
bit and I'm gonna go nearer to the
laptop which I'll do right now because
like zoom in it we could just like the
new DP eyes and you move into the Gradle
system is so aware that we can have
builds that have what only the xxhdpi in
so people who don't have xxhdpi don't
get them are sets as well bitch speaker
got me to the laptop microphone question
I think the question was can we make
apks that don't have the xxhdpi assets
in to go to some devices and yeah
someone not if that's the question
no not at the moment multiple apk
doesn't cause question Oh mister can you
make it because which so you can do
xxhdpi assets and make a very big DK to
devices that support it okay see a
developed brain close right now okay you
can definitely screams sighs so maybe
you'd want to do the smaller screen
sizes and the bigger screen sizes in
different boats I didn't think you could
do it on density need him access to
Doc's compatible screens I thought they
would have in a way of saying it is
supports hello you speaking yeah we are
we're talking talking okay this is a
little bit of fail but if we just rewind
for the last couple of minutes he'll be
able to hear what people inside so I
think the answer was no hopefully and we
have moderator now as well let's jump
into the also I should turn the camera
around see what's going on here we're in
the middle of a hall with about 2,000
people in it so if we see someone we
know will drag them in hopefully we can
get some of the android framework
engineers to come and sit on one of our
knees here we've only got two chairs
Romanies factor moderator them okay
how does the google play search index
work I have an app that is called
something to clamp it to pronounce in
Spanish but it's fine search index just
rank it's okay
twitch Bucky is Bucky join us Spock he's
not with us with ping this has given a
pretty good answer
Gohan can you read that amazing LT Nexus
for spring yeah whilst Nick decodes
Sparky's answer how does the bill play
session just where is basically the best
year yeah yeah but Spock is giving some
very good advice if moderator out
basically it saying don't use some very
generic words because they're gonna be
highly competed against Germany it comes
down to like normal stuff like we're
gonna write apps based on like that lot
of signals like a lot much like Google
search which we don't give the exact
obviously but it's the stuff you'd
expect it's gonna be things like the
quality of your app the ratings how good
your listing is the number of installs
number of people who can stall the
afternoon lots of signals like this so
generally the advice is always just
right they're really good app and
concentrate on the app quality and just
represents it very fairly in the
description if you don't try and use
like you know keywords section where you
list every single keyword you can think
of in the description because that's
actually something we're actually you
know things a sign of a bad quality app
so it's very game the system so you'll
be penalized for that kind of behavior
so just don't try to be too clever right
concentrate on quality and write a fair
description and the only exception to
that rule is and if you have a name of
an app which is quite close to a
dictionary word but a slight play on it
then sometimes I search rather than just
something called our query rewriting
where you know it says we think you did
you mean kind of very - it thinks you've
done a typo it's trying to be really
helpful in correcting it if there is a
case of that where like you would close
prediction word and people are getting
their query rewritten to the dictionary
word rather than your app's name then
that you know obviously we need to know
about so you can use the report problem
on the Google Play
and developer sports are actually poor
that to us and try and actually enter
the ranking yeah there's a great contact
form on google play developer support
where you can report things back to the
supporting so that could be one of them
hey hey smokey thanks for joining us hey
hey were you guys talking about the the
application okay so what happened was
actually that apps search result is
correctly placed but the primary title
of the oppas in English so when you
search for it in Spanish if your user
interfaces in English you're not gonna
see it at all fair enough I have the
developer gets that message then III
report it I actually reported that as a
feature request to the store that if you
get an exact title match in a language
that's not the primary locale show the
exact match I'm sorry dude this guy
can't hear what's going on but what we
do have is totally phases out it's over
there okay so go back to the location
I'll just see if there's someone else
who's joined us in the Hangout this song
with that's a picture maybe they have a
question also we have something in the
comments now they're just adding Sparky
yet Sparky's wanted to grab the next
moderator Nick would like to read it so
he knows okay
good question from Andrea the self named
one man moderator machine Kelly says
regarding user switching in Android 4.2
how does that affect Google Cloud
messaging if I register device ID is one
user on my server well other users have
different device IDs if it's a single ID
how is the notification presented to use
at a if user be is using their device I
thought you need this we're single
Freddie's place either rich or me yeah
yeah we're slightly distracted I'm just
going to show you what the conference
look like
do you know the answer so if you have
multiple users on a device they get
different registration ideas and ECM
talk to you Google account is no it's
totally gonna be different ones here try
to your Google account so yeah the good
looking with it start to say oh it's a
device and account pair yeah so
potentially if you're logged in with the
same account and the different users on
the same device you can have multiple so
what happens if the user isn't
foregrounds and and due dates that so I
think it's exact the same behavior as if
the device was off right so yeah that's
right I switched to I never account and
then all the said all my notifications
country sounds good to me I died I'd
hurt some messaging that implied that
for example you would continue to get
your Gmail in the background even when
you weren't logged in but I don't have a
source on that it was just something I
heard tell the person who writes
documentation for GCM are you looking at
the action bar question know about the
GCM I just if it can if the person who
writes up can put some information about
multi users how that works
I hope it between Sparky and okay I come
here are the joys of doing things live
from a culture at least we have new
devices in action life in the room you
have supposed to the conference floor
but comfortable you get signage the
science is very important the signage is
beautiful I just went to an awesome talk
I talked by Chet Haase lunchtime talk
tonight was just a short 30-minute talk
on the process of process and he came up
as a process methodologist consultant
yeah that's just new crystal meth
ecology crystal meth ecology yes here's
a good question because I know the
answers to it and John Souza I've
probably seen that wrong in Brazil from
it says there is is there any way to use
account picker dot new choose account
intent on the emulator
whenever on the emulator can handle this
so there's actually a subject we just
did a code lab on on Monday and if you
check my Google+ stream you'll see me
sharing all the details so you can want
to learn more about using this new
Google Play services and identity
framework so the simple answer is no if
Google Play searches like Basie relies
on an apk being installed in your device
this is like I made by the place to
other place to or silently updates these
people Play services a new device so cuz
the emulator doesn't have if you could
somehow pull the apk off of your device
and perhaps and so on the emulator or
required through some of the means that
could possibly work but I wouldn't know
anything about how to do that I'm just
try to get hold of a couple of the
Android engineers here to bring them in
make sure that we do get to interview
them all the talks are running about 20
minutes late so they should be finishing
about
okay thanks why does anyone from the
Hangout have a question I can see we've
had a few more people join us you have
something you want to talk about please
just speak right up it see people yes
he was just saying that if you have
a question is does it looks like not
next muffin okay right and so Andrew
Kelly again says I have an action bar
with several taps if I run my app in
portrait mode on the Nexus 7 running for
one two and have target SDK set to 15
the tabs are displayed as a drop this
however if target SDK is greater than 15
attacks are displayed as a second row
underneath why the change
you'll notice this is kind of like oh I
think that's picking up on some of the
flexible you know sizing behavior with
the action bar the action bar will
smartly say you know if you try and use
too many tabs and there just isn't
enough room they're gonna get too small
to be click the book actually
automatically turn that into spin and
that for you I'm getting there must be a
constant defined somewhere which says
that when you have SW 600 DP device you
know over X number 10 if this drop-down
sounds like that change but I we
introduced that in in Ice Cream Sandwich
with the Galaxy Nexus phone I'm thinking
that maybe we just at the time didn't
suspect that for tablet and the reason
that comes up in API level 15 or above
is because the Nexus 7 was our first
small tablet that was my guess on that
one fair enough
he says that he thinks
have a deep meaningful discussion about
it I can't get my internet to get hold
of chat we need to get you don't find
Chandler man for us boys you look like
an Android engineer laughing ringing
yeah green green thing is no just it was
Android you might have an opinion on
stuff
chat no manner quite opinionated so I've
been told
okay make sure slowing aside yes I'm
gonna pay attention to the next question
I'm gonna try and answer myself any live
questions doing it still I am Matt the
drunk it's very late I can't hear
anything back from you guys
I feel very talking really really quite
dare I asked you then we'll manage to
water a nexus 4 Oh Chris did you manage
to order a nexus for just a few did I
need them arrived today no tens of ships
but seventh the force haven't yet I
don't know okay yeah I heard some people
saw some pictures of tens appearing on
on the Google+ streams hopefully we get
a are shipping sorted out and tablets
have people that most are - yes okay the
expression in the moderator says it's
from cheeky a man I would like to divert
a plugin for the Google Maps app or
perhaps a lab feature dealing with the
favorite places people mark is it
possible for third-party developers to
do this yes this Google Maps it suppose
from api's or is it able to interact
with other apps so if I'm interpreting
that correctly your dance is pretty much
like no there's no kind of like plug-in
architecture you can't write a lab labs
is a feature of the application it
doesn't kind of like query the device
other people's laps yeah so the Google
Maps app on Android itself doesn't
expose that plug-in feature or lapse or
like that obviously you've got the map
view if you want to embed it into your
own application yeah or there is a
Google Maps API on so basically it
sounds like they're trying to work out
that places people have started I don't
know intimately the Google Maps API
whether or not you can query that for
your users account I don't know there
may even be an intent robust I doubt it
I somehow doubt it yeah I don't you get
access to people's favorites the places
API may know somebody's yeah I said I
don't think you have to you on device I
think your best bet is to look into the
Google Maps API and work out whether or
not you can do a do a web core and all
things getting webcore to find out the
users favorites and then go from there
how afraid us just joined us from behind
the camera fantastic Italian
counterparts try come in and say hello
I think the codelab inference without
Fredo recently yeah guys we're kind of
down there up there and make friends
over here and only I can hear what they
say I think we have a chance to look at
the new Android SDK yeah I do need it
yesterday and I read some documentation
yes tonight I want to experiment with
the new API they the daydream API okay
yes I want to create an application that
get photos from this 3d box do the quick
testing of the box and show them on the
with you that's a checked out the dating
no I'm very curious maybe you can come
back and join us okay maybe you take
this or stony at the photo table
daydream yeah which is like one that
just so everybody seen many years in
there and provide before them up from
the gallery but from the I stays very
quiet in this headpiece I don't know if
anyone else has said anything to if it's
just okay choose come on yeah come on
Paul Paul Kinlan berry is joining us
here at devoxx team Google runs three
hello what are you doing how did you get
this job a conference yeah with my html5
JavaScript all things that modern Java
developers use to talk today a birds of
a feather talk actually get eight so
have anyone watching oh yes
if anybody knows what that term came
from we're doing eight programs we
shouldn't pack what we did we never
really told anyone but it's online and
people from yeah do it now so on Monday
this week we have a three hour workshop
on integrating Google Drive into Android
applications as we had a wonderful
exciting note that application but it
was just offline shockingly offline it's
like if you if you delete it you lose
all your data and that's not really
writing he's probably like because I
made news Roboto light so that everyone
in the room who didn't have the API
level 441 SDK yet he still couldn't
compile the project without deleting the
start of it still after it takes about
an hour you go through the Google Drive
shows up online you put a few libraries
in your project
and then you can synchronize files with
a user's Google Drive I Plessy really
like so how does it feel
using the driver I really like it
giving user their own data yeah as
opposed to coming onto my server and
then really it's Carolyn on Google Drive
they can see it they can edit it online
they see it it syncs to all the devices
giving people are under future there's
no server side so that went through the
G+ stream yesterday we should repost is
there a link somewhere to be the
worksheet people want to go to my stream
I think yeah Nick butcher and plus him
and come again and you'll find that well
yeah okay alright okay
so next week we'll be there may be their
last says I have a series of PDF links
in my app I'd like to open inside my but
almost all the PDF libraries are
licensed so that I need to open-source
my app should I intense it to a PDF
viewer app or try to find a library and
build it into my app good question Mars
from Holland is there an answer down
there just one off like he says this is
a great question or draw okay so Jimmy
Chris just said Drive camera which again
so potentially you could upload its
drive and open it using our drive API
that yeah okay welcome and that is a at
least a free way of doing it
PDF is a proprietary format that's nice
Easter generally you do have to license
a product for it if you want to include
it inside your application currently if
use PB fjs it is inside a weapon is that
it isn't ugly it might be friendly
licensing potentially PDF that your
people drive for licenses solution so my
answer would be it also comes down to
the kind of data like if it's something
that only makes sense within the context
of yeah so I've seen absolutely like
textbook apps which you know they want
to keep you within the application and
just use like PDF is like the rendering
technology then that makes sense to try
and find the library whereas if it's
something where the content stands alone
then I think that lends itself more to
like the Android anyway would probably
be to you fire off an intent that you
know why we build why we reinvent the
wheel when there are apps out there like
office time to vote on child even or
annotations all that good stuff why we
bill that when you can just pass it off
so so Chris bangs uh Russia chips in
with are these guys on something thanks
for that Chris of course we have a lack
of sleep actually yeah writing
presentation sorry and then joe says yet
you could launch content to Google Drive
token file excellent session and Sparky
has put in the link to my code no can
you put that on the the comment thread
as well Sparky or if you could on the
plus Android developers many people
inside hangout me see this one
everybody to get access to it don't miss
get one of them but Richard Thompson
asks if I have an app that displays a
list of places and then places on the
map you can switch between them with a
drop-down on the action bar if the app
offers other features which is the best
way to navigate to other functions like
so why arts would be that sounds more
like kind of like filtering the same
colored data so yeah if you have the
same list and you have two
representations will get map
representation with this representation
you could use a drop-down you could use
and like overlay tabs
work quite nicely and that's it bad
situation but then if you had other
navigation options then you probably
want to go like a four-speed to get to
those you probably want to want to have
you know one kind of like navigating
education type affordance as well as
like the global navigation influence
that sounds like it's getting a little
bit too much you could do that with like
a global drop-down spinning up and then
tabs underneath to do this change
between map the list it is assumed that
before could use a flying thing flying
works well when you have a list of stuff
not so when it's live a couple of things
I feel free to like posting some
sketches of what you're trying to build
and it's a feedback it's quite hard to
talk about Sparky in the meantime you're
following the plus and all his comments
in case there are any because we can't
see them from this end on the the G+
post usually gets more questions in
there one question can show you which I
don't know the answer to does the new
booty stack inform IT support PT fluency
for low energy oh my god we can have a
conversation about this my bluetooth
knowledge is not good enough I know that
the we have bluetooth 4.0 for the Nexus
4 has it I know there is a new bridge
attack I don't know how all the
different profiles and Bluetooth API
levels just bluetooth for mean that it
has things like no energy I don't know
what Bluetooth for analysis but it means
it has health profile okay no I mean not
not in Ezra but just generally does
anyone in the Hangout have any knowledge
on Pluto tourism is I didn't realize a
big player personal area network with it
and I used it to work from Android
straight away yeah I just
Blue Men nobody nobody in the Hangout so
we've got one question in the Google+
thread if you wanted to tackle that one
I was still on the kind of Bluetooth one
if anyone had any insights
no just I even looked this up sorry Joe
Wikipedia Wikipedia version four says it
has bluetooth high speed and Bluetooth
Low Energy wikipedia page says Bluetooth
4 has low energy yeah okay yeah sorry I
don't think we're at that level of the
Bluetooth API yet though no no I don't
think we are either but because I've had
quite a few questions about it now I'll
try and look it up during the week and
maybe we can talk about it three maybe
we need to do an Android one person
Bluetooth spend after a blanket yet he
may she bring lots of people to the
table they all talk together okay has a
question from the Android cool so in-app
purchasing and Google Checkout why can
we not have a callback functionality
like a normal Google Checkout
transaction it should be important that
we know the states of a payment
especially for systems created by
developers that require licensing based
on a complete and successful payment
yeah it's an in-app billing question why
can't we have a callback
good feedback yeah we're taking on board
a lot of the in-app payments feedback at
the moment like the play team took on
board a lot of feedback for their
developer console and produced a new one
we're taking on board feedback for not
billing and we'll see where that leads
us
firstly I would like updated baby guys
I'd like to get prices being able to get
prices there's a lot of people kept from
conferences every time we stand up in
front of an audience they want to they
have to get prices and similarly the
states of transactions like this are
very important so thanks very much for
joining us a call them emailing me in
and if I pruned it I'm sorry if you want
to go any funny offensive isn't it like
what was a political asylum just this is
my normal face yep doing I see the dark
top these aren't going to be available
on par ladies calm talking about you
should check out the schedules both some
really really cool talks I'm really
looking forward to one from chin
romantic n called for butterfl where to
get some really technical information
about the Android rendering system
there's a really really good three hours
three hour tour chapter about yesterday
which was full packed full of them tips
and tricks and how to get to the bottom
of performance issues I learn a lot so
we'll have to share those links for the
parlays women online on the UT plus
tricks that people can see them yes so
we were just up in chat romans' what's
new in Android talk they said that
without 560 million activated devices
I'm not sure I heard that number before
I was doing five hundred million
totally they question you understood
nothing okay yep just a question for
Chris in the moderator someone says what
do you got too many Nexus 4's can I have
one sorry that was me
we did something similar in chat talk
when there's anyone I didn't hear I saw
Chris pop up so I'm guessing the answer
if I believe you
they'll cancel the orders right Amy sir
yeah yes I ordered locked five and
rattled free to 16 to 16
good for you yeah we had a few people
who managed it with multiple they
haven't had any trouble of letting the
stop I read that those nexus in Germany
yeah yeah there were people here at
devoxx who have VPN through to Germany
trying to find the devices I think the
whole thing was quite painful any like
questions any live questions or let's
just type something in we will we'll try
and bring some more information to you
on Britain's expect in the coming weeks
you might not be able get it next week
maybe we can even get a pretty pension
ear from oh just the api's kannan next
question yes okay so Ali in Chicago says
his content provider testing possible
with multiple authorities and he needs
to test Apache operation but I cannot do
that with current test case classes as
they can be only be map-21 Authority
our friend of searching his memory bytes
somebody's got a PC might better have a
quick have anything no one's come in
from rob em in London saying he has a
path an SVG which his SVG vector which
she's drawing to canvas using draw path
as I've jellybean that seems to be a new
optimization that stops it drawing any
of the path is below 0 0 ie there are
negative path lights is a new
optimization is there you find him don't
let him get away because he knows this
question would you know the answer why
should I come down and it we don't get
in the show we will reply in the
moderator
so I'm guessing yes I believe that he
really and support the club path and to
be done by the hardware rendering
pipeline as I thought one one right so
that sounds like it could be exactly
this so if it was previously being done
by the software pipeline and then we
switch to the new hardware rendering
pipeline you might perhaps you this time
changing behavior and you just find out
yeah you did
you could yeah if you're talking like an
oil pipeline you could get the view and
say software types set set layer type to
software which will turn off the
hardware accelerated a pipeline and see
if you get the old behavior and then you
can be sure that it is like the hardware
software rendering I'd imagine it is it
sounds a lot
oh okay so I might just mean jumping out
jump Union yep
just the last question I can see in the
moderator here comes from Gregory mince
saying he has several crusher ports
saying reporting a sequel Lite exception
which says can't upgrade read only
database integration 0 to 3 and it only
occurs on some devices particularly one
you eight eight six zero something
device many ideas why just make that a
little bit more context from my day is
he trying to it wasn't what sir Joe
Hawaii a five by close Hawaii device
Huawei tries yeah yeah yeah I think they
probably is as well so if it's a device
specific issue like if you working fine
on a bunch of her devices and I'd say
for now I would blacklist the device in
the supported device section of the
place of console and then I will try and
even get hold of device or perhaps use a
service like testdroid calm to try and
you know debug issue it's not you're
going to be able to do much offhand here
without more logs yeah it's a strange
one great great learning database no
suspect issue I think those bucket
sitting about might be when you have
space yeah if you can get any more
details of the code that you're running
through the database upgrade any stack
traces that you're seeing put them into
moderator or come back next week with an
update of question bit more context look
internally yeah we're all back to the
keys being able to replicate it again
same
get out of the device and now like
virtually gone physically but you can
always have a look in your Google Play
Developer console and then there have a
look at crash reports and what we should
hope you see the stack trace I'm
guessing that's where you're seeing
anyway if you can get the stack trace
out of there and send it to us ready for
next week's office hours we can talk
with an answer for you he's linked to
some stuff in the question so here's a
given for you guys so if you get your
android 4.2 device and you want to plug
it in to the USB to get your USB
debugging connecting up to your Android
SDK
you're going to hit the settings screen
you can either drag down one from the
top or twice photography settings get
switch settings you'll scroll down to
the bottom and you won't find developer
options in oh my god hopefully it's been
going around a bit on G+ but because we
have 560 million users and only a
fraction of the MER actual Android
developers we've hidden the developer
options now so you now go into write
down to the bottom of settings to the
about time and start tapping on their
build right you tap it and then it says
five four three two one you keep tapping
and then it says congratulations you are
now a developer and then developer
options will reappear if you're on
multi-user system on a new Nexus 10
tablet go to be the primary user
multi-user system the first person he
locked it as the primary user and they
have control over they can delete for
account about the debugging options just
and I throw that in there because we've
already had a question once and we're
bound to get it a couple more times and
so if we exhaustively moderate event in
the energy person at some place Michael
back asks what our favorite and API sin
their Android work months you are
I think we've given our favorite so I
went for presentation API in the media
returns rich went the daydreams did you
say it's for me you're mister widget I
won I have missed with you I would you
let me find his app
that's result a second result now if
which it said you a beautiful widgets
damn you're beautiful widgets are just
so pretty and it lets me and emanating
okay okay yes a lock screen widgets the
same API is not the widgets one feature
favorite feature now just going to tell
what look screen how much for me to
flirt but yeah lots for immediate smooth
feature because I won't end them on low
and the music app to both that not to be
midget so when I'm running I can you see
both and I just wanna hit the power
button I'm listening to but I think it's
a good question open up to you guys who
live in the Hangout here you if you've
had a chance to take a look at the 4.2
api's what's the things you know you're
most excited that can't wait today don't
let one by one starting with Chris and I
think the presentation API I've never
played with me yet but I think the power
of it and what you can do with it this
example in their API demo and this
example yeah I like the presentation as
well because but as well I saw dreams
and in the support package before it
launched I thought what on earth is that
so he did spot dreams in support well
that's presentation presentation
presentation presentation I think I'm
gonna go for day games I don't know if
it counts us in any cat very much but I
honestly I think my favorite new feature
is improved bidirectional tech support
because I'm really excited about opening
up Android to that next couple of
billion users
improved by directional tech support
yeah that's that's the big tip with that
is debuts is the new constants as well
and you see is gravity left
do you write in your layout so you to
like gravity the text at one side or the
other you now want to be looking at
using gravity so I think we yeah API in
the yeah there's a goat you whether as a
goat capable of transportation a monkey
something about how fast be simple yeah
it's on Chrome on Chrome if you go into
the debug options these debug options no
that's a problem if how many goats have
been transported codes have been
transported as a deep my watchin crime
how many coats have been transported as
a debug option in chrome one of the
Collins
Paul suppose modding Paul Kinlan he's
never tried it himself and no intent
Fredman session pregnancy pregnancy
friends no deeper Chris was asking about
that on G+ it easily so that was three
for presentation three for people who
care about just watching stuff literally
one for the rest of the world a few pro
tips as well and new stuff in developer
settings
there's a few new interesting settings
you want to take a look at first one I'm
gonna say is yeah if you want to devote
these presentations but you don't have a
TV or miracle suspect there's a new
option to emulate there's a new option
to emulate a second display so that you
can develop for it and your device will
see a second display a second one ago
talked about is going to be developer
option over drop over drop so there's a
new option in there so you can tell the
hardware rendering pipeline to kind of
like overlay how much over drawing
you're doing so I think that's one of
the biggest problems in applications
comments so if your turn to splitting it
do too much but we're all lazy just
don't do just don't do any work you
don't have to basically it's a cool tool
in developer options which will like
overlay in like blue if you're drawing
twice or green if you're drawing three
times or like Red's if you like drawing
the pixels five times which is extremely
that's a really really cool way to know
if you're doing too much work and then
you can use the and the chaser tracer
for OpenGL ES tool and which is part of
the SDK to actually step through your
rendering operations and work out you
know
oh I'm drawing the opaque background and
I'm drawing a completely opaque layer on
top of that so you know that's
completely wasted pixels Superboy
absolutely yeah no man ran through some
examples yesterday when he'd been doing
this reducing the number of layers of
three smooth scrolling lists and don't
be drawing everything so five times we
just spotted a Jake Wharton walking by
as well use it like now got no choice
but to come on and say hello so we're
doing a regular office hours hangout and
of course she's no sound very rich in
here like it here all the guys and they
say you know my name Jake Wharton we're
good square and I do an open source
stuff
speaking about other open source
projects that I have done in square puts
out and hopefully getting some
excitement for all these projects and so
that everyone can make their apps so if
you don't know Jake makes a action bar
sure and major contributors
actionbarsherlock
no but it was in the top ten yeah
combined okay in the last five minutes
any more questions
I can probably answer the one about the
sequel met as sequel database one
earlier about the getting the error
about the read only the I've come across
to read only problem before it was on
early versions of Android 2 and the best
way to get round it was to do a get
right to belong create and then close
the database straight afterwards it's
pretty hacky but it seemed to solve the
issue in almost every case I think
no we've kind of had a couple requests
for whether there's gonna be an official
dock for the Nexus 4 and other devices
so daydream will work the Nexus 4 the
Nexus charging and daydreams will work
when it's dropped into that yes when you
sit down you have the choice to tell you
when to dreams only choices are when
dots when on power
fixa school's official wireless charger
I haven't seen what myself yet but we're
using it so we use a so you can get
these things embracing the standard
through the wireless charger but it's
really nice just I thought my strike
here to build into my do we know if I by
default Android dreams a dreams of
Electric Sheep do we know if my default
Android daydreams will achieve any games
maybe it would be okay I think we're out
of time yeah and say thank you for
joining easier from Devils so you can
hear it and make it yeah with a little
bit of a brief rundown on that is the
general what's new in Android the yeah
and Jake's talk on new thing all that
awesome
okay and yeah you can go to my profile
and I've shared a link to the code lab
that we gave on using drive to sync data
between your apps on the web and
everywhere so that everything stays in
sync again thank you very much so the
people who joined us live in the Hangout
helps out massively today when we
couldn't hear or speak
conferences yes cheese thank you very
much
now guys fear by everyone